so so uh you know i'm looking at a lot
about what's going i'm looking a lot
what's going on say in in new york and
california
it's not just that our economy is being
gutted our manufacturing is being sent
over to china
we don't even make our own medicine
anymore that was the craziest thing when
we had a pandemic
and we're like we need medicine quick
call china because we don't have any
factories that can actually make it
the coronavirus really made a lot of
people become aware of uh
of the situation like when like medical
supplies
even things like kettlebells you
couldn't get it because everything was
made in china
i mean right now it's really hard it's
still hard to get a lot of
specific uh equipment professional
equipment bicycles
it's all made in china it's interesting
on the medical side like
we actually do do a lot of
pharmaceuticals but a lot of the raw
ingredients
so the things that go into the drugs
come from china
and there's nowhere else that you can
get them and the craziest thing too is
uh rare earth minerals right which we
use for i guess smartphones among other
things
we get them we get it almost exclusively
from china right
japan does did recently find like a big
surprise but it's everywhere
it's actually not uncommon to find it
there are rare earth minerals in the us
yeah yeah but we just go for it china
we're just going to give all of our
money and keep printing it
now we've got 35 percent of all us
dollars just being printed like crazy
we've got to wait to get some we've got
new york california michigan these
states
have violated the constitution beyond
any record like i mean listen
if you come out you say we have an
argument about gun control i understand
the second amendment but you can still
have a right to keep and bear arms with
some restrictions
there's an argument and people actually
argue it although many people are now
becoming rather too absolutist because
of you know the riots and the craziness
but in in uh you look at new york
andrew cuomo was like if you're
protesting
you're okay you have your rights if you
are pro joe biden please come out dance
in the street and drink champagne
together
but if you want to go to a church never
going to happen
if you want to run your business because
you're running out of money and you need
to feed your family
no dice this is extreme degrees
of authoritarian despotic
i don't even know is there a word more
harsh than i can get
psychopathic malevolence where he's
basically sent
you know he had nypd going to jewish
schools with children
and the cops would point their phones
inside the windows to film them
to prosecute nypd police officers went
undercover to a restaurant ordered food
and then as soon as the person delivered
it arrested them that's the level of
uh depravity coming from the likes of
cuomo
and no one no one in this country is
doing anything in it the police officers
support it
so you know to wrap to make sure i'm not
trying to get off on a tangent outside
of the china stuff
when we hear that there's chinese
authoritarian communism and things like
this
the american people seem to just roll
over and take it for the most part in
these blue cities
but but i'll tell you i don't see the
political willpower from trump
supporters or anyone who could do
anything to stop it at this point
they're going to completely destroy the
economy and they already have
the federal debt to gdp ratio is now at
128.6 percent we're we're we're dropping
and collapsing so quickly
that when many people talk about
thucydides trap and i talk are you
familiar with this at district
i talked about it quite a bit several
months ago that there's been fear for
years that we will eventually get into a
full-scale war a hot war with china
because there are rising economic power
well i guess there's one way to avoid it
have our own politicians destroy this
country from the inside out and then
there won't need to be a war
you know i think uh we did this we did
this episode
pretty early on the coronavirus called
the cure for coronavirus is not
authoritarian
authoritarianism and it was based on the
idea that like
the chinese communist party was trying
to use their model of controlling the
coronavirus which is
like locking people in their homes like
literally welding them into them welding
people in their homes
dragging people out of their homes to
put them in quarantine you know
arresting people like beating people up
for being on the streets when there was
a lockdown
um and kind of like providing that as a
model
for other countries as to like this is
the way to deal with it and you did
a virus media somewhere like hey you
know it's mind it might be a little
authoritarian but it's working
yeah like you know they they got rid of
it so it kind of works so i think
in a way like the things that you're
talking about in new york or
the excess of things that they're doing
in california and these different places
like
you know it was almost like it was like
it happened
in china that they did this lockdown
then it happened in italy that they did
the lockdown it kind of gave permission
in a way for all of these
you know people uh politicians in
different areas to be like this is the
way to deal with and because
of it yeah and because china lies about
uh the actual coronavirus numbers it
seems effective
but the numbers in china are completely
fake it's it's obvious if you look at it
yeah i really wanted to ask you this but
it's kind of strange that these kind of
top democrats even
the new york city mayor today bill de
blasio came out and just
plainly said i'd like to say very
bluntly our mission is to redistribute
wealth so it's very interesting seeing
these democrats kind of mimic
the language and some of the behaviors
of the communist chinese but
from your sources from from the people
you talk to on the ground
what's really going on there did they
defeat the coronavirus because we're
seeing a lot of photos of them raving
and partying and having these huge
the marathon the street marathon yes how
does like how does
how do you guys make sense of this story
of this deadly pandemic
everywhere but china's having street
parties and raves
uh at the same time did their lockdowns
uh
work like what what's going on here well
first of all i know you have some
specific things you want to say about
that shelly but
um like over the past couple of months
you keep seeing like
certain cities in china declaring uh
wartime measures to fight the
coronavirus because there's
oh some rumor that maybe like somebody
got a case and then suddenly they need
to test 70
000 people in a city and they can do
that in like three days because it's a
horrible authoritarian regime but so you
get the sense that
uh it never did stop there is still
something happening
uh the extent of which we can't know and
i know you have some specific things you
were talking about earlier
oh yeah just the idea that you know well
i mean in terms of the numbers there's
no way to
like you cannot there's no way to even
guess because it's not really going to
be based in reality
because like their gdp numbers the gdp
numbers aren't real
um you know there was you know china's
been organ
force organ harvesting from dissidents
and
you know it turns out that like some
people did a study and found out that
like
the whole since 2015 they've claimed
that they only have organs coming from
you know voluntary donations you know
sure sure i get a couple kidneys i don't
need yeah and then they
basically these researchers found out
that their voluntary donation numbers
and their transplant numbers were all
fake they all
mimicked a quadratic equation
almost perfectly so are they are they
actually harvesting organs
they are from political prisoners they
are doing
uyghurs they're definitely doing organ
transplants
their official numbers are fake yeah yes
yeah surprise surprise isn't their real
estate all fake too
uh yeah uh yeah
you know i watched uh i was watching a
video someone posted on facebook i
remember what it was but maybe you guys
know
where a guy was explaining the the
warfare strategy of china
is exploiting the weaknesses of a nation
that they accept so
if you allow free speech then we'll
support protests against you
if racism is a very sensitive issue then
we'll inflame it and we'll just keep
pushing it and pushing and pushing it
and that what we're seeing right now is
actually
the fifth generational war full scale
with china
they know that if they actually you know
crashed some u-boats on the shores of
california and ran in full speed
they might have a very large ground army
but the the people would fight back and
the americans would win
air superiority for for one thing plus
all the aircraft carriers we got
so what they're doing is subversion
manipulating our systems stock market
buying land control you know they're
they're coming in they're undermining
all of our institutions
it's working and it's being it's
collapsing underneath us
and i wonder when we hear things like
that from bill de blasio
these people like build i look at the
chinese communist party i think they're
very smart
very very very smart they understand why
they had to have some kind of
capitalistic system
in their country to actually allow it to
expand economically
because you know the things they were
doing very early on kind of didn't work
like didn't they kill all these birds at
one point or something the sparrows
yeah all right that was like didn't do
anything did it like they had kids
literally pulling
grass out of the ground because grass
was bourgeoisie
so like clearly that stuff didn't work
but now you have people like bill de
blasio who clearly is not a smart person
saying we're going to do this you know
readership wealth so it seems like
they've bought and paid for as many
elites as they can you've got the
thousand
talents project program or whatever out
of these universities where
these people are essentially spies it's
really amazing they're not getting
charged with treason
and then the way they've gotten a hold
of universities is is horrifying
is it is it what is it is it a
coincidence then that the universities
are the epicenter for the most part of
this
woke broken theory
critical critical theory that makes them
hurt about what you're talking about and
have no knowledge
none what's up no no
so no no no never never never we're
playing it safe right shelly
super safe apparently well i think that
in a way like the chinese communist
party is happy to see us destroy
ourselves
but um they don't really care
if we follow communism as an ideology
that's not really what they care about
what they care about is
having the u.s become weakened and so
they can
continue to you know um
oppress all these other countries and
like you know specifically their growing
influence in
asia pacific yeah definitely so so uh
the reason i bring this up is we had a
story in the new york times
uh it was updated a couple days ago but
it was from about a week or so ago
where a university professor said we
should not give the vaccine to the
elderly because they tend to be more
white
and we need to level the playing field
with minorities
which is one of the craziest things i've
ever seen written in the new york times
where they outright said this professor
believes
older white people should die to balance
the number of harvard professor
uh no no university of pennsylvania oh
okay oh but at the same time
at the same time at the same time from
the college fix we have a story about
cornell
which is mandating only the white
students get the vaccine
so the critical race theory stuff is
completely
nonsensical it just makes literally no
sense to be like well it's racist
to give the vaccine to the you know to
the white people so we're going to give
it to the minorities at the same time
only the white people should be forced
to get it it's like that theory makes no
like none of that makes sense right
this ideology clearly has no
no end point no goal no success it's
just
chaos and so when you see this coming
out of universities
you see things like this the thousand
talents program i'm not i don't want to
get
too conspiratorial but i think when
you're talking about china trying to
subvert this country
and they have a program in which they
buy out university professors
and then you have many university
professors who are espousing nonsensical
ideas that will only destroy this
country
i kind of feel like there's some lines
to be connected there maybe i'm wrong
the thousand talents is mostly about
science and tech stuff because what they
really want to do with that is
steal us technology and bring it to
china literally
paying professors to bring their
research not not to say that
specifically they're using thousand
talents to espouse this kind of weird
you know far left or critical race
theory stuff just that i think
if they're willing to do that in
universities would they not be willing
to
push this other kind of ideology because
it eats us alive from the inside
i do think that the the critical race
theory is interesting in the sense that
the chinese communist party is like what
you said about the video where they'll
use our weaknesses against us or
they'll use our strengths against us and
make them weaknesses so
with the racism thing that's one of the
things that they've definitely
been using especially in australia well
in australia but also here to
when people started blaming china for
the coronavirus that was definitely
racist
it's racist to talk about it asians
asians are white
yeah that's the new thing right yeah
yeah i was very happy to tell
you yeah i was very disappointed to
learn i was actually i was really
excited because it turns out that i'm
double white
because you know yeah right so i get to
be white twice so is that like
is that more power you have i don't know
does this mean super privilege you are
or aren't going to get the vaccine
uh well for my allergies i'm not oh um
i actually do have allergies yeah yeah
not legitimate back to our topic i think
i think i think you guys are hey quiet
down we're talking about something
interesting
allergies tell me more yes i think you
guys were talking about the larger
divide and conquer agenda and it is
interesting to see a lot of special
interests from china do give a lot of
money to the universities
and it is kind of exemplified as we saw
with again i'm gonna bring this back to
mayor bill de blasio because his
administration
during the early onset of the
coronavirus was saying
it's fine don't be racist come out to
the chinese day parade everything's
gonna be fine
don't worry racist and then next week
he's literally threatening martial law
where even andrew como had to
stop bill de blasio and said wait hold
on there you're pushing it
too far if you're going farther than
andrew coma wants you to go
you know you're a lunatic and you
absolutely lost it and he has been a
part of this larger divide and conquer
supporting black lives matter protests
openly calling for demonstrations
meanwhile telling you you can't have
dinner with your family because it's
going to spread the coronavirus and kill
everyone and and this black lives matter
thing also we have to admit here
is being exploited by the chinese as
there have been many chinese diplomats
that have come out and said the united
states is racist
you know look at we support black lives
matter there was even a police officer
in in hong kong
that was screaming at american
journalists there black lives
matter as he was beating the crap out of
the dissidents
in hong kong so we have to understand
there is an element of this exploitation
of our racial divide by the chinese
whether it's being weaponized or just
exploited i think is is something a
topic of debate that i think we should
talk about
i think the it's their favorite thing to
bring up and it's
the racism because it's like that's the
number one thing that they can like
anything they can hit us with i know it
hits yeah and it's it hits a nerve in
the us and also like
it's everything they do is what aboutism
in a certain sense where like if you try
to bring up
human rights atrocities in china the
first thing they'll do is
bring the racism or whatever steve kerr
did this
remember the nba guy he was like i don't
go around asking about our police
brutality problems you know and we got
we got issues we got to deal with it's
like bro
don't talk about police brutality we can
you want to talk about concentration
camps we have to did that happen with uh
was it mark cuban somebody who oh yeah
who was like oh
yeah that was also terrible because he
was like china is a customer
yeah but we should i treat you that's a
problem
but we should you know we should start
in our own like clean up our own house
yeah
that's a fundamental problem you need
they talk about china like it's our
customer instead of oh
the chinese communist party has
concentration camps and harvests the
organs of people
who have wrong political beliefs i think
that's one thing like joe biden
came out with a with a statement during
human rights
international human rights day which was
the 10th and what was disappointing was
that he kind of focus
he was like yes there are many human
rights atrocities around the world
but then was like we have to talk about
systemic injustices
here in america and whatever and that's
fair but
it's kind of like it is it is very
similar to chinese propaganda in the
sense that they're always talking about
like
well before you can talk about what's
wrong in other countries you have to
clean if you're not perfect you cannot
talk about anything else
jordan peterson says clean your room
bucco you know you you can't
you see jordan peterson's communist yeah
that's what i'm getting here i'm saying
he's secretly subverting
american um yeah i mean you can't
compare the two it's not apples and
oranges when you compare black lives
matter to the uyghurs
especially when you look at the kind of
xenophobia and the treatment of
blacks in china and there was amazing
incredible
video that that came out that was off
stunning showing what was happening with
the chinese government literally blaming
black people for the coronavirus
inside of china kicking them out of
their
own homes kicking them out into the
street and then and then this is the
country
lecturing us about black lives matter
they made a commercial
where there's a black man put into a
washing machine
and you guys i'm sure you saw this and
it was it was it created an
outro an uproar in the us because so for
those who haven't seen the commercial
there's a chinese woman and a black man
she pushes the black man in the washing
machine and he comes out chinese
and there was a there was outrage in the
us and china's china's response was
they're like are you americans you bite
swa you crazies you're so sensitive grow
up
they didn't care there was also
blackface yeah the cctv
yeah every year they have this uh
communist uh gala
new year's show and yeah last i think
was last year they had the uh like
somebody dressing up
like oh the africa yeah like china and
africa and how they're like helping all
the african people and they had like an
actress and black face
and and as like ever like so many of the
uh you know
experts from africa we've talked to are
saying like this is colonialism it's a
neo-colonialism
so i remember spending time in africa
doing reporting and i was surprised how
many chinese nationals were
at the airport at the hotels and they're
building a chinese surveillance
yeah i mean i was in kenya and zimbabwe
and somalia
and even in somalia i saw some chinese
nationals which was pretty uh surprising
to say the least but
talking to almost every african a lot of
them brought up to me
the chinese are here they're taking over
they are the new colonizers this is
crazy
what's happening here and i was shocked
to the level of how many africans were
talking to me about this seriously
whether it was taxi drivers whether it
was waiters whether it was random people
that i walked
into or is interviewing they're like you
should really take it take a look into
china
and how they're essentially taking over
all of africa
and usurping all of our natural
resources and buying off our politicians
and it was surprising because i didn't
know about it until i was in africa and
actually saw it on the ground there
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you